[Applause]
hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic guy
remember it so you don't have to as me
if you know I'm a big lover of classic
nostalgic it shows from Ninja Turtles to
transformers to the Disney Afternoon to
Fox kids he has some pretty awesome
shows in our time which is why it really
pains me to say this but at some point
you just have to accept reality kids
shows now are much better than they were
before and that's so weird to say seeing
how much I love the shows I grew up with
and will always hold a place in my heart
but when you look at shows today like
Adventure Time gravity falls and Steven
universe there's no question that
they're pushing the boundaries of what's
normally expected out children's
programming at least what was expected
in the past don't get me wrong we still
have plenty of mindless stuff but these
shows are going the extra mile to not
only fascinate kids but adults as well
and in a way that was never done in the
past for so many years we complained
about how there's nothing good on for
kids help we complain how there's
nothing good out for adults
well now intelligent funny
thought-provoking kid shows are
surprisingly in competition yeah they're
no longer the rarity they're kind of the
norm
and in a bizarre world where things seem
to make sense the more effort in the
show the bigger the hit it is so how and
why is this possible
hasn't kid stuff for the longest time
been just that kid stuff well not always
people forget when the other of
animation started it was for both kids
and adults but the more we got used to
it the more it made sense to aim it more
towards kids because you could be more
exaggerated and expressive which kids
can relate to easier but even then some
of the adults putting it together didn't
slack off on the effort Disney a Warner
Brothers to animation Giants are prime
examples of that the Warner Brothers
cartoons focused more on comedic writing
that you would find in most vaudeville
acts and Disney despite it usually being
seen as more kid oriented throughing
much more artistry and design that may
not get as big a laugh as goofy or
Mickey but offered more of an artistic
expression that weren't in most
children's entertainment at the time
both of these studios challenged what
was seen as mere kids entertainment and
were both big hits because of it
so big that years later they're still
worth big money most homes when dream of
being without at least a few Disney
films and everybody young and old still
knows the Looney Tunes by name this led
to the conclusion that kid shows can
lead to big moolah and show business
still being a business tried to
capitalize on it and make them even more
profitable the problem was they focused
in the wrong areas so for a while we're
concentrating less on good characters
and story and instead more on what else
on toys so every episode of he-man my
little pony or whatever we rushed out
with new characters vehicles and
accessories whether they made sense in a
coherent story or not and we ate it
right up we didn't care if it made any
sense to what was going on you know
what's tough and we love stuff the more
stuff we could have related to that show
the better but the problem they
eventually figured out was stuff things
he-man in My Little Pony RAM for a while
but we eventually grew up and saw it as
kid stuff kid stuff was only for kids
and just lame to adults but that were
truly the case why are some of the
adults wearing Looney Toons t-shirts why
do some of the adults still go to Disney
World even if they don't have any kids
shortly after producers started to
realize that the reason Warner Brothers
and Disney was still making money is
because the writing was good and
timeless we appreciated them because we
can enjoy them both as kids and adults
which from a marketing standpoint could
double your audience so show start to
take a few more chances Animaniacs
Batman gargoyles these were shows that
adults could watch with their kids and
enjoy on an entirely different level
because they tried harder than most
other shows they went that extra mile
and introduced new jokes themes and
styles that never been done before at
least not with this kind of effort don't
get me wrong we went to crap shortly
thereafter and for a while we hit a bit
of a dead zone roughly around the same
time as that Dark Age of movies but the
people who watch those other great shows
eventually grew up to make their own
shows and guess what they were
influenced by those shows that put in
the extra work thus they had a new bar
to hold themselves to now most kids
shows and movies for that matter are
expected to entertain adults just as
much as kids at least the ones are
expected to be big hits and even today
DVDs toys and other merchandise are
being bought not
just by adults but for adults throwing
people dress up to say thank you to the
dedication these creative teams put in
their work but come on we grew up with
great stuff so why is this stuff
apparently better part of it is while
those other shows are great and changed
a lot it was going through a
transitional period so creators at the
time didn't know what they could get
away with the dark writing in Batman was
never dabbled within this much detail
nor the adult jokes experimented with an
Animaniacs because there was more focus
on these new elements we still hold out
today they were still bound by certain
understandable rules Batman still had to
fight someone Animaniacs still had to
keep their stories to a half-hour
nowadays the limits have been stripped
more and more comedic series don't have
to be comedic all the way through
dramatic series don't have to be
dramatic all the way through stories can
continue an entire season if need be
and even the show based on comedy and
action can have little to none in some
episodes and still get critical praise
for it
Tiny Toons is great but you wouldn't see
them dive into heavy drawn-out turmoil
like you would an adventure time nor
tackle as many potent issues become with
those shows in the past is that they
were still experimenting and didn't know
how far they could go the pro is that it
gave way to so much more experimentation
today arguably more than what was ever
done in the past there's a few reasons
for them one technology these shows
usually look beautiful and that's
because computers have sped up the time
to get them done you'll also notice that
the designs of many of these characters
are much more simpler than ones of the
past they do this because it gives way
to faster animation while also allowing
more time to focus on color backgrounds
and of course the story second feedback
nowadays is instant even though we still
have focus groups the Internet is the
most blunt and massive feedback there is
so if something doesn't go over well
they can know right away and make the
appropriate changes he'll even use some
of the backlash in the show sometimes we
cannot give up hope
well that's just silly I don't like that
third is people finally see the
possibilities Sheils like lost an
x-files demonstrated that continuing
mystery can be a big draw but if you
focused more on that and not as much on
the characters it couldn't lead to a bad
experience if you don't deliver on the
ending shows like gravity falls in
Adventure Time have similar mysteries
but that's not their drop their draw is
their environment their characters and
the fact that anything is possible so
even if the last episode doesn't give a
satisfactory answer to the mystery
people won't feel ripped off because
they were in it for money now that's not
to say lost or x-files have bad
characters but when compared to the
likability even complexity of these
characters they're just gonna last
longer but how can something as simple
as these characters be even more
interesting than these characters well I
just said in that sentence they're
simple what do you go remember more the
complex inner workings of Matt Damon
from interstellar or how badly the
coyote wants to catch the roadrunner
chances are we're gonna be quoting
beatbeat before any line of dialogue in
this film with KITT shows you have to
keep the motivation simple so they can
follow it but what they go through to
achieve it is where the complexity comes
in because these worlds they create are
fuelled by imagination rather than logic
more possibilities are available too
with new ways of tackling and explaining
issues that were never present in kid
shows before issues you never thought
would be in a kids show like abandonment
anxiety sexuality inferiority depression
control these shows are exploring these
issues in everything but name you can
have characters with goofy identities
like the Ice King and the vampire queen
but when you put them in a loving
situation where one has almost entirely
forgotten the other it's one of the most
heartbreaking things you can watch it
can also help people in real life
identify with the pain of Alzheimer's
avatar the last airbender and legend of
korra educate on the themes and ideas of
East Asian philosophies yeah
East Asian philosophies and all
explained in a way that children can
understand there's a power in Steven
universe where two people can combine
their mind and bodies together in one
meaning they have to work together to
share both their mental and physical
abilities there's so many levels of
identity being addressed here it will
make Katka
even political issues can be brought up
both adventuretime and Korra gives some
pretty interesting conversations about
how much control a government should
have they're not just based on cookie
cutter villains trying to take over the
world they're legitimately compelling
arguments of how much do you sacrifice
and how much do you let slide both
walking the tightrope of what's
ethically acceptable gravity falls not
only has hilarious writing but it also
litters its episodes with puzzles and
clues encouraging kids to solve a
mystery that even most adults haven't
figured out yet even sexuality plays a
role while government was still taking
its time to legalize gay marriage shows
like Steven universe Korra and even
shows intended for really younger kids
like postcards from Buster we're getting
the jump on what they already knew was
right introducing kids to gay and
lesbian couples before their mind to be
exposed to any prejudice none of these
would be tackled in the toy centric
shows of the past even the ones that
started the change when quite touch a
lot of these subjects no this doesn't
mean I love them any less but it does
mean I should acknowledge when an art
form is clearly advancing TV for both
kids and adults has gotten so good
recently butts the TV for kids that's
even more
we know we can show them anything and
for years we took that as an excuse to
merely profit and distract while
sometimes educating now we're using it
not only to legitimately entertain and
educate but also enlightenment they're
used to expand their mindset and show
possibilities instead of just
introducing information they're
introducing wisdom and through the best
way possible
without them even realizing they're
learning anything at all they're fun and
exciting and silly but also smart
artistic and insightful they play with
mood character and different ways of
telling a story than any kids show has
done in the past a five-year-old can
watch Adventure Time and enjoy it but
then grow up years later and enjoy it
for entirely different reasons it's a
strange time now where talent and
respect for your audience actually
equals big box
maybe people finally got tired of
rewarding the same repeat programming or
maybe the means of recognizing that
frustration have just gotten more
obvious but whatever it is it's leading
to some great work new classics new
characters and new stories that will not
only be remembered years later but
appreciated on levels that we never
appreciate kids programming before
over the years pioneers saying kit
should be given our best instead of our
leftovers are being heard and explored
for brand new ways discovering educating
creating and all while having a great
deal of fun the generation that watches
these shows now will then grow up and
bring us even newer and greater
possibilities because hey we gave them a
great starting point to be inspired by
it's a great world of imagination
intelligence and ingenuity that
hopefully isn't slowing down anytime
soon Allen astounds our Critic I
remember so you don't have
[Music]
[Applause]
you
[Music]